[Musique]
à
bon alors il rigole on rigole mais il
est en train de me demander comment on
écrivait court court court lequel bourg
à laquelle du court courir est en cours
c'est au prs hockey quand est-ce que tu
l'emploi avec le thé pour quelqu'un qui
est pas prêt à y aller parce que je la
mettais la barre vraiment il a eu un
court il ya trois contes
jus c'est vraiment une enfant 1 3 tu
joues avec ce scotch tas
mais qu'est ce tu fais pas l'enfant
aurait été vraiment une gamine institut
va avoir 30 ans bientôt à bas l'état du
scotch sur le nez là
à juju arrête départ l'enfant arrête ça
suffit
[Applaudissements]
d'autant que m'énerve
c'est de toucher les cas c'est le même
toit
[Musique]
non
l écueil à la police je vais à
l'étranger avec une rose j'ai moi
monsieur excusez moi monsieur s'il
fallait que je fasse une arrestation
n'aurait pas besoin de me mettre les
menottes parce que tu viens d'arrêter
mon coeur
c'est mignon mais c'est que je peux t'en
marqué pour s'agit en fait de
l'acquisition ça te dérange pas
maintenant
[Musique]
ou alors ce soir ce soir jadore jadore
jadore jadore ce soir au menu alors là
ce soir soir et
j'adore
[Rires]